new clues are emerging this morning on
just what if anything is living in
Scotland's famed
Loch Ness a scientist curious about the
lakes fabled monster went looking for
evidence any signs of life in the
largest and second deepest body of fresh
water in the British Isles it's a legend
that has captured the world's
imagination for years would there be a
prehistoric creature living in the
waters of Scotland's ancient lake Loch
Ness since st. Columba apparently came
across a beast over a millennium ago
rumors and sightings of a large
unidentified creature nicknamed Nessie
have persisted and when this famous
photo later exposed as a fake was
published in 1933 it triggered an entire
Nessie searching industry Steve Feltham
has been monitoring the Loch surface for
27 years well we know his sonar keeps
picking up contact with things that are
bigger than the fish and people keep
seeing things that are bigger than the
fish so that's what we're hunting for
whatever the explanation is last year
professor Neal Kamel decided to take a
new approach and study the DNA of the
Loch as we move through the world we're
always losing bits of skin or eyelashes
were here and it's the same for fish or
other animals that are in Loch Ness
after months of research he delivered
his conclusions to the wading media this
week I think we can be fairly sure that
there's probably not I joined scaly
reptiles most likely and possibly more
unnerving is a group of giant eels to
life-long Nessie hunters the findings
have done little to dampen their hopes
to say we have found evidence of eel
which is like saying we've found
evidence of fish in a Scottish Loch so
the hunt for the elusive Loch Ness
monster looks set to continue it's sure
will I mean the history of the industry
of tourism built around Loch Ness in its
monster create a group of giant eels I
like that I don't
that could turn into a month that is a
month that is a monster there you go the
Loch Ness monster did any of you see the
deep it is a mess
yeah yeah
[Music]